president and mrs. Trump will fly to
France tonight for this weekend's g7
summit the annual meeting has
highlighted divisions between President
Trump and some of the strongest US
allies Ouisa Jang is at the White House
we shall why do officials there say this
year's g7 will be very different than
previous years oh good morning Anthony
for the first time in the gatherings 44
year history it will not end with the
leaders signing a joint statement the
host French president Emmanuel macron
said the break in tradition signaled a
deep crisis in democracy
last year President Trump refused to
sign the agreement and left the summit
early amid disputes over trade this year
the group will take on several big
issues including a weakening global
economy Iran tension and the possibility
of Russia rejoining the group after it
was kicked out in 2014 over the
annexation of Crimea President Trump has
recently said it would be good and
appropriate for Moscow to come back but
McCrone said that can't happen until
Vladimir Putin agrees to take steps to
resolve the crisis in Ukraine there's
also a newcomer this year who will
likely make the event a little more
interesting new British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson who's known for being
brash and bold will be there the
president has reportedly told aides his
meeting with Johnson is the only bright
spot of the trip now after the g7
President Trump will head off to Poland
to commemorate the 80th anniversary of
the start of World War two and as we've
been reporting he was supposed to move
on to Denmark but abruptly canceled that
leg of the trip because the Prime
Minister said it would be absurd to talk
about the u.s. purchasing Greenland
which is something the president wanted
and Tony selfishly that means we had to
suddenly unpack our bags to Copenhagen
to thank for is that the White House was
you thank you very much